Wow what we have here this is the
biggest river catfish pan gasps Tina
dawn hypothalamus that I have ever seen
this fish weighs almost 70 pounds and is
almost 5 feet in length it's a really a
huge fish beautiful fish this fish is
also known as the iridescent shark
catfish because of its shape its shaped
a little bit like a shark and sometimes
when it swims on the surface it'll raise
its dorsal fin and it'll look quite a
bit like a shark as it swims along this
fish was caught here in the totally SAP
river in Cambodia and these fish move
out of the tonlé sap lake every year and
into the Mekong River we believe to to
complete their spawning migration to
complete their lifecycle the head on
this thing is the same size as my head
and this almost rivals the size of some
of the smaller Mekong giant catfish that
I've seen these fish have a very
delicate skin no scales and they have a
slime layer that protects them from
infection we're tagging and releasing
these fish to learn about their behavior
so this fat fish has an individual
numbered tag it's fish 3385 so this is
the 3,000 fish that we've tagged in the
last four years and what we're doing is
we release these fish back into the
Tonle Sap River so they can continue
their migration and then if a fisherman
somewhere downstream catches this fish
again we learn where where it's moved by
this individual identification number
why hold so now we've uh now we're in
the middle of the river we want to
release this fish away from the bank so
that it doesn't get caught again and
also want to make sure it can swim on
its own I'm gonna hop in seems to be
swimming pretty well really nice big
fish just needs a few seconds to get
acclimated to the river water again so
we release the fish and it disappeared
and just saw it jump once and then go
back down so it's all we can do a little
naked